-The former top prosecutor
for the Capital riots
said on Sunday
that the evidence in the attack
could support sedition charges,
as federal investigators
continue to examine
former President Donald Trump's
role
in fomenting the insurrection.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
When you're a former occupant
of the Oval Office,
there are a few
different directions
you could go
with your post-presidency.
There's the Jimmy Carter route,
of charitable work;
the Bush route,
of painting portraits of dogs
like a weatherman filling in
at the last minute for Bob Ross.
Then, there's the Obama route,
of making movies for Netflix,
kitesurfing
with Richard Branson,
dressing like an Italian
fashion designer,
and making up excuses
to hang out with celebrities.
[ As Obama ]
Here's an idea for a podcast.
Me and, uh, Bruce Springsteen
just kind of, uh...hanging out.
"Mr. President,
that sounds great.
What would it be about?"
It's called "Renegades."
I came up with the name myself.
"It's great!
What's it about?"
Sometimes!
[ Laughter ]
Little Steven will be there,
but he has to share
a mic with, uh, Bruce.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Donald Trump,
as is his wont,
chose and charted
his own course.
He's decided to spend his time
creepily shuffling
around his Palm Beach resort,
like the ghost
of a retired dentist
who drowned in a water hazard
on the 18th hole.
[ Changes accent ]
I was looking for my ball
[ Laughter ]
and I forgot to come up for air!
It was a Titleist.
They're not cheap!
[ Laughter ]
Every weekend,
a new photo emerges
of Trump in the same getup --
red hat, white Polo,
slacks that seem to be rising
faster than the sea level.
He spent all that time
hanging out with pillow man
when he really should've
befriended the UNTUCKit guy.
See how much more
comfortable he looks?
But, no, Trump would rather
wander around his own resort
like a lost grandpa
who's supposed to be
watching the kids at the mall.
"We do have reports of a couple
of kids playing Keep Away
with a glow-in-the-dark dildo
at Spencer gifts.
Does that sound
like your grandkids?"
[ As Trump ]
That does sound like them, yes.
His business and finances
are apparently
in even worse shape.
His net worth fell
by $700 million
during his presidency,
the Manhattan D.A.'s
investigation
of his business and tax returns
is intensifying,
and his Mar-a-Lago resort
just partially closed,
so they could use it
as a pop-up vaccination center.
Wait, no, I read that wrong.
It closed due
to a COVID outbreak.
[ Laughter ]
My God!
COVID follows this guy
like a rain cloud
following Daffy Duck.
His rallies, the White House;
now, Mar-a-Lago.
He's like a walking COVID test.
If you're ever, you know,
in physical proximity
to Donald Trump,
you should just, you know,
quarantine for like two weeks,
just to be safe.
It really does perfectly capture
the state of the modern GOP
that their standard bearer,
the guy they tried
to overthrow democracy for,
is now a financially broke
and ghost criminal.
At this point, I have to assume
he's also being investigated
by Mulder and Scully.
[ As Scully ]
Mulder, look at this
COVID cluster.
What could be causing this?"
[ As Mulder ]
Have you ever heard of the
coughing swamp ghost
of Palm Beach?
Five or six years ago,
we used to make jokes
about his skin tone and, now,
he doesn't even have one.
He's the color of spackle.
I guess it makes sense.
He's a landlord
because he looks like the layer
of paint you'd find
after peeling back the wallpaper
in a Manhattan apartment.
And, on top of everything else,
even his iconic plane,
the private jet he used
to fly everywhere
during his first campaign,
has now apparently fallen
into such disrepair
that it's not
even flyable anymore.
-The glory days
of the gold-plated jet
that Donald Trump once used
as his calling card
seem far away.
It is now grounded
and in disrepair.
-It was the ultimate
status symbol --
Donald Trump's Boeing 757.
A regular presence
on the 2016 campaign,
at his marquee events,
there was his plane.
Today, however, the massive jet
sits abandoned
at an upstate New York airport,
one engine mostly missing;
one wrapped, idle,
in apparent disrepair.
According to records,
it hasn't been flown in months.
-It's been sitting on the ramp
for at least a year or two
and the left engine's been
taken off, probably for service.
-The crown jewel of Trump's
fleet, now, future unknown.
-Wow, who broke this story,
The Daily Metaphor?
He's finally coming face-to-face
with the consequences
of his actions.
Trump's like a character
from an ancient Greek myth
who doesn't let Hades
finish describing the deal.
"You will be blessed
with all the riches
in the world, but, in return --"
[ As Trump ] Deal!
"Don't you want to hear
the rest of the trade?"
I'm good.
Just get me on that Pegasus.
"It's just, technically,
I have to explain
the terms of the deal."
That's what my lawyer's for.
Where is he, by the way?
I told him to meet me
at the River Styx.
[ As Giuliani ]
River Styx?!
I went to Styx concert!
[ Laughter ]
Oh, Rudy!
And not only are Trump's
finances, his resort,
his business, and his plane
all in shambles,
but he's now also reportedly
under multiple investigations,
including an investigation
of the riot at the Capitol
on January 6th.
The federal prosecutor
who previously
led the investigation
of the riot
told "60 Minutes" on Sunday
there's likely enough evidence
to meet sedition charges.
-I personally believe
the evidence
is trending towards that
and probably meets
those elements.
-Do you anticipate
sedition charges
against some of these suspects?
-I believe the facts
do support those charges
and I think that,
as we go forward,
more facts will support that.
-I have to say,
I'm not sure why we have
to have federal prosecutors
on "60 Minutes,"
telling us something
we already know.
Either charge them
with sedition, or don't.
When did criminal investigators
start doing press junkets,
like movie tours?
"Obviously, there were
a lot of pranks on set.
It was a fun investigation."
I mean, I'm no lawyer and I
don't think sedition charges
should be leveled lightly
or often,
but if a violent attack
on the Capitol
to impede the lawful counting
of electoral votes
isn't sedition, then what is?
They stormed
the House and Senate,
injured 140 police officers.
I'm not saying
they were likely to succeed
in overthrowing
the U.S. government,
but that doesn't mean
it's not sedition.
You're still guilty
of attempted robbery,
even if you get caught
breaking into a museum
in the middle of the night
because you forgot
to silence your ringtone.
"I'm in.
I'm going to steal the diamond
and then quietly rappel
down the south wall.
-♪ Po, po, po, po ♪
-Oh, no!
-♪ PopoZao, PopoZao ♪
-It's my mom!
Oh!
She loves K-Fed.
Hey, remember when Sal,
earlier today, said,
should we switch it to my dad,
so I can say,
"It's my PapaZao"?
And we all like, "No, Sal.
[ Laughter ]
That will tarnish
your reputation."
We did him a huge solid.
[ Laughter ]
And, now, it's up to Sal --
"Am I'm going to leave that in
or am I going to cut around it?"
[ Laughter ]
Looks like someone else's
integrity's on trial.
[ Laughter ]
There's already extensive
evidence in the public record
of detailed planning
by militia members
in advance of the January 6 riot
and proof they were coordinating
their movements
as it was happening
and, not only are prosecutors
apparently considering sedition
charges for the rioters,
they're also examining the role
Trump himself played
in fomenting
those seditious acts.
-Has the role of former
President Trump
been part of your investigation?
-It's unequivocal that Trump
was the magnet
that brought the people
to D.C. on the 6th.
Now, the question is,
is he criminally culpable
for everything that happened
during the siege,
during the breach?
What I can tell you is this,
based upon, again,
what we see in the public record
and what we see
in public statements in court.
We have plenty of people.
We have soccer moms from Ohio
that were arrested, saying,
"Well, I did this
because my president said
I had to take back our House."
That moves the needle
towards that direction.
Maybe the president is culpable
for those actions.
-In short,
you have investigators
looking into
the president's role.
-We have people looking
at everything, correct.
Everything's being looked at.
-Wow.
He's being investigated
for fomenting
a violent sedition
and he doesn't even have his jet
to flee the country.
If he gets indicted,
he's going to have
to book a commercial flight
under a false name
and dye his hair.
[ As Trump ]
So what do you do?
Oh, insurance.
That's a great business.
I was the president.
Uh, uh, I mean,
urrrrr,
of my condo association.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
That was close.
[ Laughter ]
So there were militia members
who planned and coordinated
their attacks
and they were there
at Trump's explicit direction.
Remember,
he even advertised the date
ahead of time and said...
He sowed a violent insurrection,
like an old guy hanging
outside a liquor store,
inviting teenagers
to a house party.
[ Changes accent ]
Be there.
It's going to be wild.
We're going to hotbox
my '86 Camaro.
Bring pizza!
[ Laughter ]
The previous president fomented
a violent insurrection
to overthrow democracy
and the vast majority
of his party
either went along with him
or stood by silently
and let it happen.
There needs to be
consequences for that,
especially since the GOP
is still trying
to rig our democracy in their
favor through other means,
whether it's their ferocious
assault on voting rights
or their attempts
to challenge anyone
who wouldn't go along with their
attempt to steal the election.
Trump left our democracy
in the same state
he left his plane...
-Grounded and in disrepair.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe.
Wear a mask.
Get vaccinated.
We love you.